book on congresswoman Kat camek of
Florida is here a member of the House
Homeland Security committee
congresswoman always terrific to see you
what do you make of this hypocrisy and
by the way the migrant flights that were
coming in in the middle of the night
into New York State into Westchester
County no one would have ever known
about those if not for the reporting of
the New York Post
no I mean this is the height of
hypocrisy I mean you think about the 78
flights alone that came into
Jacksonville Florida in the dead of the
night that took a freedom of information
request by members of Congress to get
that from the Biden Administration yet
50 illegals get flown into the
playground of the Rich and Famous you
know home of Barack Obama that all of a
sudden they're outraged and keep in mind
that Obama was the original architect of
the so-called kids in cages but now
they're on their front doorstep and oh
my goodness we have to get the military
involved I have to give a hat tip to one
Governor DeSantis for his his shrewd
Acumen on this and for having the
courage to take the fight to those on
the left those that choose to ignore and
as in his own words said virtue signal
but also to you and the entire Fox team
you guys are the only Network that has
been covering this Epic crisis that we
have been facing no other network has
touched it they don't even want to
acknowledge the two million dollars that
the democrat-led city of El Paso has
allocated and the 25 charter buses that
they've been sending out to Sanctuary
cities but it's only when Governor
Abbott and Governor DeSantis take action
that it becomes a newsworthy for them
shame on those networks shame on these
democrat-led cities and shame on the
Biden Administration for ignoring the
public health humanitarian and National
Security crisis that he has created at
our Southwest border congresswoman the
New York Post has a couple of op-eds
with headlines like this with Martha's
Vineyards meltdown maybe Dems will
finally understand illegal immigration
problems and also this Dems are upset
that DeSantis has made them look in the
mirror on migration and the fact that
just to use one example of many Kore
Jean-Pierre calls moving migrants to
other places in the United States cruel
what's cruel is laying a foundation
where human traffickers and Drug
traffickers profit from Human misery and
suffering and even death whether it's
the hundreds again as the United Nations
and Governor Greg Abbott mentioned this
in the last hour the United Nations says
that our Southern border is the
deadliest in the world there are
hundreds of migrants who have died what
51 who died trapped in a tractor-trailer
but then also the thousands upon
thousands tens of thousands of Americans
who die from fentanyl poisonings where
is where is the outrage over that from
the left
well what we've seen from the left is
that they live in an alternate reality
that's just the fact of the day they
don't see the cruelty at the Southwest
border because they refuse to go there
they want to live in this alternate
reality where their open border policy
is somehow Humane no it is inhumane I
can tell you firsthand having been there
five times that what's inhumane is the
cartels that viciously gang rape young
girls as young as nine years old I have
seen this myself it is the human
trafficking that takes place it is the
over one hundred thousand families that
have lost loved ones because of the
fentanyl that has been peddled and
trafficked across the border the only
thing that is inhumane and cruel is the
Biden administration's open border
policies and that's what's going to
change and Americans will never forget
the open border policies that have
simultaneously created a Public Health
crisis a humanitarian crisis and a
national security crisis allowing
members of the International terrorist
watch list to come across this border
and gang members drugs they have
destroyed our national security in that
respect and we will not let them forget
it before we go congresswoman California
governor Gavin Newsom is also calling
out Ron DeSantis and Governor Abbott
calling on the Department of Justice to
consider kidnapping charges he tweeted
this I'm formally requesting the doj
begin an immediate investigation into
these inhumane efforts to use kids as
political pawns it seems like that Gavin
Newsom tends to wake up to these issues
when he can use it as a political weapon
but not before
yeah I mean it's kind of concerning the
obsession that California governor
Newsom has with Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis I think there's maybe a hint of
jealousy in the fact that we are the
freest state in the nation and our
education is is top in the nation and
you know they're falling at the bottom
of every bad list California is it's a
very strange Dynamic I mean he should
even talk to his own in-laws who fled to
the free state of Florida but I think
Governor Newsom would be best if he
focused on the issues in his own
backyard the homelessness the drug
crisis the people that are fleeing so
much so that he has to run ads in other
states telling people to come home he's
got to focus on his own issues before he
comes at my Governor Ron DeSantis and
I'll also really quickly point out that
it at least one County I believe it's
Santa Clara County in Northern
California is Distributing a Narcan in
all the high schools because of the fear
and the danger related to fentanyl
overdoses in our high schools among
teenagers it's heartbreaking absolutely
heartbreaking I I mean as a parent I
can't even imagine having my high
schooler come home and say that I got
Narcan today absolutely heartbreaking
Florida congresswoman Kat camack thank
you for being here thank you hey
everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me and
my co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights